en el último vídeo empezamos a ver
evidencias de que el adn es la base
molecular de la herencia y vimos eso
gracias al trabajo de eibar y mccarthy y
mclean quienes trataron de identificar
si lo que actuaba como principio de
transformación en los experimentos de
griffith era adn o eran proteínas y los
invito a que vean ese vídeo si lo que
estoy diciendo les suena poco familiar
pero incluso su trabajo en 1944 no fue
visto como una prueba concluyente se
consideraba que era evidencia fuerte
pero no evidencia concluyente porque
recuerda como lo hicieron tomaron a la
cepa lisa inactivada por calor recuerda
que la cepa lisa en el experimento de
griffith era la cepa virulenta y fue
inactivada con calor cuando esto se
paliza inactivada por calor fue
inyectada a un ratón no le hacían nada
al ratón pero si se combinaban la cepa
lisa inactivada por calor con la cepa
rugosa
una manera esto transformaba a la cepa
rugosa en la cepa liza en la cepa
virulenta por lo que tomaron a la cepa
lisa inactivada por calor y la separaron
en sus diferentes componentes y
finalmente fueron capaces de aislar uno
de esos componentes que fue capaz de
transformar a la cepa rugosa enlace
paliza y luego le aplicaron todo tipo de
pruebas químicas a este componente y
dijeron hay muy buena evidencia de que
este componente es adn pero no fue
concluyente porque bueno tal vez no
purificaron el componente adecuadamente
o tal vez tenía un poco de proteína tal
vez fue en su mayoría adn pero
probablemente lo poco de proteína que
todavía quedaba ahí era la responsable
de la transformación por lo que la
comunidad científica no estaba diciendo
esto se ve muy bien vamos a suponer que
todo esto es cierto y sigamos adelante
ellos querían continuar haciendo pruebas
y especialmente probar lo de diferentes
maneras y la prueba concluyente no vino
sino hasta unos años más tarde hasta
1952 cuando alfred jersey y masachs
decidieron estudiar al bacteriófago de
dos voy a escribirlo por acá
bacteriófago t2 este es un fallo que
infecta bacterias cuando escuchamos la
palabra 'fago' nos estamos refiriendo a
los virus ahora ellos sabían que el
bacteriófago t2 estaba compuesto por
proteínas y adn y ellos no sabían pero
nosotros ahora sí lo sabemos que es una
cubierta de proteína y hay adn en el
interior pero desde su punto de vista
dijeron si observamos los componentes de
los que está hecho este virus está hecho
de proteína y adn proteína más adn
y sabían que este virus cuando infecta
bacterias inyecta algo a las bacterias
así que inyecta
algo
y ese algo es lo que secuestra a la
maquinaria genética de las bacterias
para empezar a producir más del
bacteriófago tv2
así que si ellos pudieran identificar
ese algo que se inyecta a las bacterias
si pudieran averiguar si ese algo era ya
sea una proteína o adn
entonces ellos demostrarían de manera
concluyente cuál es la base molecular de
la herencia y ellos en realidad eran
bastante escépticos de los experimentos
de héiber y mccarthy y mclean
de hecho jersey chase en realidad
pensaban que estaban por demostrar que
las proteínas eran la base molecular de
la herencia y recuerden todo este tiempo
las personas pensaban que las proteínas
eran estas moléculas complejas que
tienen estas diferentes formas y todos
estos aminoácidos diferentes así que
parecía ser mucho más probable que
pudieran codificar toda la complejidad
de la información genética que el adn
ellos no tenían una precisión real de la
estructura del adn en ese momento por lo
que idearon un experimento para
averiguar qué es ese algo que él
bacteriófago t2 está inyectando será que
ese algo es proteína
o
adn así que esta es la cuestión así que
lo que hacen es que desarrollaron dos
lotes del bacteriófago de dos un lote
del bacteriófago t 2 lo cultivaron en
presencia de fósforo radiactivo fósforo
32 en el otro lote cultivaron al
bacteriófago t 2 en presencia de otro
isótopo radiactivo pero esta vez fue
azufre este es azufre 35 así que por qué
hacen esto
bueno el fósforo se encuentra en el adn
así que en este primer lote el marcador
radiactivo se va a incorporar en el adn
y en cuanto al segundo lote el azufre se
puede encontrar en las proteínas y no en
el adn por lo que el azufre radiactivo
serviría para etiquetar algunas de las
partes de las proteínas y si te estás
preguntando cómo se pueden desarrollar
estos lotes radiactivos bueno pues se
deja que los virus secuestran células en
un medio que tiene o bien el azufre
radiactivo o el fósforo radiactivo y
conforme se reproduce
se van incorporando ese material
radiactivo
ya sea en la proteína o en el adn de los
nuevos virus que son producidos así que
ellos se produjeron al bacteriófago t2
en presencia de fósforo radioactivo y
sabían que de esa manera el adn
obtendría el fósforo radiactivo y luego
con el azufre radioactivo ellos sabían
que las proteínas obtendrían el azufre
radiactivo y luego con los bacteriófagos
t2 de cada uno de esos lotes infectaron
más bacterias y dijeron bueno los
bacteriófagos van a inyectar algo en las
bacterias y para averiguar qué es ese
algo que se inyecta en la bacteria
tomaron los productos de cualquiera de
los dos escenarios primero los mezclaron
para que todo esto que se encuentra
afuera pudiera ser retirado de la
superficie de las células de las
bacterias y luego lo colocaron en una
máquina centrífuga la máquina centrífuga
es una máquina que gira rápidamente si
tomamos un tubo de ensayo y lo colocamos
en esta posición y le ponemos un tapón
para que esté cerrado y luego lo hacemos
girar de esta manera lo hacemos girar
muy muy muy muy rápido lo que va a pasar
es que se genera suficiente fuerza g de
manera que el material más pesado va a
precipitar a la parte inferior del tubo
de ensayo oa la derecha
dado que está de lado y el material más
ligero va a gravitar hacia la izquierda
y resulta que las bacterias las células
bacterianas son más pesadas por lo que
las células bacterianas se van a ir
hacia el fondo del tubo de ensayo y van
a formar un material al que llamamos
pellets o sedimentos y todo lo demás el
fluido y las partes sobrantes de los
fados van a ir a la parte superior del
tubo de ensayo y llamamos a esto
sobrenadante y así ellos dijeron mira si
nos fijamos en el sedimento que ellos
sabían que contenía las células
bacterianas o incluso se podría decir
que contenía los restos de las células
bacterianas si nos fijamos en el
sedimento si este contiene fósforo eso
significa que el hada
y nuestro adn radiactivo o nuestro adn
etiquetado logró entrar en las bacterias
pero si el sedimento contiene azufre eso
significa que la proteína es la que
logró entrar en las bacterias y lo que
encontraron es que había fósforo
radiactivo en el sedimento lo que les
permitió concluir que el adn del virus
es lo que fue inyectado en las bacterias
y no las proteínas y luego dijeron vaya
a ver y mccarthy mcleod estaban en lo
correcto el adn es el principio de
transformación el que puede entrar y
secuestrar la maquinaria genética de las
bacterias para producir más virus así
que esto es muy muy muy importante una
vez más
empezamos con méndez diciendo hey
tenemos estos factores hereditarios que
aparentemente se separan y clasifican de
ciertas maneras volver y sharon dijeran
el comportamiento de los cromosomas
durante la meiosis cuando las células se
reproducen parece relacionarse con los
factores hereditarios de méndez
morgan comienza a proporcionar evidencia
al respecto tenemos los experimentos de
griffith con los ratones y las bacterias
y diciendo que hay un principio de
transformación eib erin mcleod y
mccarthy dicen cuando tratamos de
purificar este principio de
transformación
parece que el adn es lo que realmente
importa y después jerseys validan esa
idea de manera más concluyente